sehr geehrte damen und herren ich darf
sie herzlich begrüßen zu pressegespräch
mit generalmajor rudolf striedinger dem
stabschef der verbund durch ministerin
der general wird seine erfahrungen aus
der live beobachtung der massentest in
südtirol beziehungsweise die erfahrungen
die das bundesheer vom einsatz anfang
november bei der testung in der slowakei
gewonnen hat egal ich da versuchen ihre
wurzeln klang sehr geehrten damen und
herren herzlich willkommen hinter rosso
auch wie sie einleitend schon gehört
haben geht es also darum dass ich sie
kurz darüber informieren welche
erfahrungen wir insgesamt und da meine
ich jetzt nicht nur das bundesheer
gemacht haben aus den massen testungen
die in der slowakei und in südtirol
stattgefunden haben
der grund warum wir uns dafür
interessieren ist die tatsache dass
solche testverfahren auch in österreich
durchgeführt werden sollen
diese beiden beispiele die wir im
ausland hier beobachtet haben sind
durchaus unterschiedlich ausgelegt sind
auch sehr unterschiedlich durchgeführt
worden und gerade deswegen weil sie
unterschiedliche konzepte verfolgt haben
sind die erfahrungen die wir daraus
ziehen können durchaus sehr wertvoll
weil man im einen und anderen fall das
positive und das negativ für jeweils
identifizieren kann und dann für sich
selbst anwenden kann
mein erfahrungsschatz aus dem bereich
der slowakei ergibt sich aus der ein aus
einer seite aus den durch das
österreichische bundesheer
durchgeführten einsatz von
sanitätspersonal das waren 33 personen
dort für zwei tage im einsatz
sanitätspersonal dass es die abstriche
durchgeführt hat auf der anderen seite
natürlich durch die mediale
berichterstattung aus der heraus man
natürlich auch einen gewissen eindruck
von den bildern bekommt und drittens
natürlich durch besprechungen die wir
mit den slowakischen behörden
durchgeführt haben um auch die direkt
den erfahrungen
der unterschiedlichen verantwortlichen
auf deiner seite des gesundheitswesens
auf der anderen seite auch des militärs
in erfahrung zu bringen
um rückschlüsse für uns selbst ziehen zu
können
südtirol ist ein anderes kapitel in
südtirol wurde ja das wissen sie
die bevölkerung letztes wochenende
getestet und da war es noch sehr
wertvoll dass wir einen persönlichen
lokalaugenschein dort durchführen
konnten und uns von den dortigen
verantwortlichen insbesondere des
zivilschutzverbandes im detail einweisen
lassen konnten und uns auch insbesondere
in der stadthalle von bozen im detail
dieser einzelnen stationen anschauen
können um zu sehen wie ist gehört das
praktische prozedere und warum läuft was
wie und wenn es jetzt also darum geht
die eine oder andere besonderheit zu
erwähnen
so möchte ich auf die slowakei
zurückkehren und betonen dass dort im
großen und ganzen das eine militärische
operation war die sehr stark von den
streitkräften getragen wurde
rund ein viertel des dort eingesetzten
personals waren soldaten die ja so für
den gesamten prozess und die logistik
verantwortlich waren und dafür gesorgt
haben
wenn man sich jetzt ins detail anschaut
was man auch medial gesehen hat so gab
es dort relativ lange warteschlangen auf
der einen seite und auf der anderen
seite doch auch räumlichkeiten wo leute
auf ihr testergebnis nach dem anti gen
test gewartet haben
das sind zwei beispiele dafür dass wir
sagen vielleicht gibt es methoden und
möglichkeiten genau diese beiden
ansammlungen von personen gruppen
möglichst zu vermeiden
um eben ansteckungsgefahr möglichst
stark zu reduzieren
für uns bedeutet das dass wir
wahrscheinlich unseren prozess sehr
stark digitalisieren werden dass wir
insbesondere wenn wir in dem ersten
schritt anfang dezember die lehrer und
kindergartenpädagogen testen sehr stark
auf it lösungen drängen weil damit ein
geregelter zugang zu den teststationen
vereinfacht wird und ermöglicht wird und
auf der anderen seite auch das
testergebnis nicht vor ort abgewartet
werden muss sondern digital zur
verfügung gestellt werden soll
dieses positive positive beispiel bzw
diese konsequenz aus der erfahrung aus
der slowakei haben wir nämlich in
südtirol gesehen
dort gab es unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten für die bevölkerung sich
anzumelden oder bzw einfach zu kommen
und insbesondere dort wo eben es dem
zufall überlassen wurde wann wer zu
einer teststation kommt kam es zu
längeren wartezeiten
die natürlich durchaus unerwünscht sind
und wenn wir jetzt in die kennt noch
kältere jahreszeit kommen einfach
vermieden werden müssen
daher wird es bei uns diesbezüglich aus
meiner sicht lösungen geben die lange
wartezeiten jedenfalls vermeiden helfen
sollen
wir haben in südtirol gesehen dass durch
eine verfügung des landeshauptmanns eine
verordnung das antigen testergebnis für
verbindlich erklärt wurde wer positiv
getestet war automatisch für zehn tage
in eine quarantäne gestellt das ist in
südtirol deswegen so gemacht worden weil
man dort die erfahrung gemacht hat dass
die antigen testergebnisse äußerst
valide sind also sehr zutreffend sind
und es kaum einen verein in südtirol
gegeben hat wo durch einen pcr-test das
ergebnis des antigen tests aufgehoben
wurde oder falsch infiziert wurde
dieser vorgang wie den wird es bei uns
bei der lehrer testung so noch nicht
geben unsere absicht ist dass wir bei
positivem antigen test jedenfalls eine
pcr testung unmittelbar im anschluss
anhängen wollen um sicher zu gehen dass
die das testergebnis konstant und
valider ist und damit auch die
entsprechenden behördlichen maßnahmen
gesetzt werden können
ansonsten gab es eine vielzahl von
kleinigkeiten im detail
wir haben in beiden bereichen
festgestellt dass sehr viel in den test
stationen mit papier gearbeitet wurde
dass dort sehr viel manipuliert werden
musste papier daten im computer
eingetragen wurden in back office etc
das ist etwas was sehr viel
personalkapazität bedarf auf der einen
seite was fehlerquoten natürlich
deutlich in die höhe hebt und deswegen
ist auch hier unsere absicht möglichst
stark in einem einzelnen programm
die digitalisierung durch den gesamten
prozess von der buchung bis zur
bekanntgabe des testergebnisses
durchzuziehen
ansonsten gebe es noch eine vielzahl von
dingen die man jetzt noch im detail
erläutern könnte aber fürs erste dürfte
das einmal ausreichend sind aus meiner
sicht
herzlichen dank darauf geben ihre fragen
bieten die suche doch mal kurzes zeichen
damit wir mit einem mikrofon hin kommen
keine bitte verlaufe ich hätte drei
fragen zum einen sie sagen es soll sehr
viel über digitalisierung passieren
jetzt gibt es aber viele menschen die
warum auch immer keinen zugang haben
sich zum beispiel online anzumelden und
dann online auf ein testergebnis zu
warten welche lösungen überlegt man da
dann das zweite gibt es formal schon das
ersuchen des ministeriums um die
assistenz des bundesheeres und das
dritte ist angesagt das soll dann gleich
anschließend einen pcr-test jetzt für
die lehrerinnen und lehrer folgen die
getestet werden passiert es dann auch
gleich
vor ort oder was plan von tag also
bezogen auf die problematik dass nicht
jeder internet fit ist und alles zu
hause hat befinden wir uns was die
lehrer testung betrifft insofern auf
einer eher guten seite weil wir davon
ausgehen dass also jeder lehrer und
wahrscheinlich auch jeder
kindergartenpädagogin jedenfalls
zumindest ein handy hat das ist
ausreichend dafür und oder sonstige pc
ausstattung gedanken was die massen
testung der bevölkerung diesbezüglich
betrifft muss man sich machen sie
verständlich aber das sind wir noch
mitten in der arbeit bezogen auf die
leistung des bundesheeres ist es
festgelegt dass das österreichische
bundesheer für dieses testverfahren zur
assistenz aufgerufen wird nachdem es
sich um einen gesundheits behördlichen
vorgang macht wenn es darum geht zu
testen ob jemand cupid positiv ist oder
nicht das sind was die
gesundheitsbehörden die das bundesheer
zur assistenz aufforderung und die
dritte frage war die frage nach der
bewertung die pcr testung ist ganz
grundsätzlich so vorgesehen dass windows
ergebnis des anti gentes positiv ist die
person sich an einem noch zu
festzulegenden ort im bereich der
teststation einfindet um einen pcr tests
durchzuführen
franken ich hätte auch zwei fragen die
erste ist wie hochrechnen sie wie die
beteiligung sein weil es jedoch recht
knapp vor weihnachten ist glauben sie
dass ein paar leute nicht mitmachen
konnten einfach weil sie angst hätten
über weihnachten dann in quarantäne
gesteckt zu werden und die zweite frage
bezieht sich auf die bundesländer die
kritisiert haben dass sie nicht
beziehungsweise erst sehr spät in die
ganze planung einbezogen werden worden
sind wie ist der stand der dinge mit dem
gespräch gestern abend zunächst mal auf
die beteiligungs- frage
das ist jetzt eine sehr schwierige sache
hier überhaupt eine prognose machen zu
können deswegen komme ich mit der
information wie das in anderen ländern
war in der slowakei gab es eine sehr
hohe beteiligung jener personengruppe
muss man dazu sagen
die vorgesehen war für die test um das
waren ja die ab 10 jahre bis 65
verpflichtend und da darüber hinaus
freiwillig verpflichtend insofern als
dass dort durch rigorose maßnahmen in
aussicht gestellt bzw auch umgesetzt
wurden für die personen die sich nicht
testen haben lassen nämlich automatisch
in einer quarantäne zu sein
in südtirol war es so dass der zustrom
der bevölkerung außerordentlich hoch war
nämlich deutlich höher als erwartet was
die südtiroler behörden durchaus auch
vor logistische herausforderung gestellt
hat weil sie nicht erwartet haben dass
sich so viele leute testen lassen
das dürfte wahrscheinlich auch deswegen
herrühren zumindest hat man uns das am
sonntag zu mittag nachmittag
argumentiert dass die lage in südtirol
bezogen auf die versorgung von
insbesondere intensivpatienten schon
sehr kritisch ist und daher auch ein
gewisses bewusstsein in der bevölkerung
vorherrschte jetzt endlich einmal
festzustellen wer zwar positiv ist aber
keine symptome hat und es daher nicht
weiß und auch das test ergebnis war sehr
interessant in südtirol
man rechnete ursprünglich mit rund fünf
prozent positiven das ergebnis waren
aber rund ein prozent positive also von
dem rund 320.000 personen getestet
worden sind waren 3200 tatsächlich
positiv und damit gemäss verordnung des
tiroler landeshauptmanns automatisch für
zehn tage in quarantäne gestellt und
gleichzeitig auch mit einer
entsprechenden information für den
arbeitgeber versorgt dass der weiß okay
das ist jetzt quasi eine
mehr oder weniger behördliche verfügung
dass man sich in quarantäne zu begeben
hat das ist jetzt der punkt wo ich sage
wir setzen jetzt derzeit nichts
man wird sich man wird eine durchaus
relativ hohe beteiligung bei den lehrern
erwarten können
bei der gesamtbevölkerung ist es
durchaus eine berechtigte frage des
zeitpunkts aber viel früher wird es aus
rein logistisch organisatorischen
maßnahmen durchaus nicht möglich sein
und alles andere befindet sich
diesbezüglich noch in bearbeitung
wenn es um die frage der einbindung der
länder beziehungsweise der betroffenen
stellen geht so ist dieser prozess
derzeit voll angelaufen
wir haben ja übers wochenende unsere
militärkommandanten entsprechend in
kenntnis gesetzt und beauftragt
unverzüglich mit den landesbehörden
insbesondere den gesundheits und den
bildungs so gesundheitsbehörden und
bildungsdirektionen verbindung
aufzunehmen um den gesamten prozess
einmal zu starten
auch mit den einsatzorganisationen wird
gesprochen insbesondere mit der
feuerwehr aber auch mit den
rettungsorganisationen weil wir die
feuerwehr zur unterstützung benötigen
wenn es darum geht den gesamten vorgang
bei einer teststation auch entsprechend
zu begleiten für eine gewisse ordnung zu
sorgen
manipulativ oder sonstige administrative
tätigkeiten entsprechend zu unterstützen
und die rettungsorganisationen brauchen
wir insbesondere dafür dass wir
zusätzlich zum militärischen per
sanitätspersonal auch rettungs aus dem
zivilen bereich
rettungssanitäter oder sonstiges zivile
sanitätspersonal bekommen damit wir eine
größere dichte an
personen die die abstriche machen können
bekommen weil je mehr dort dabei sind
desto reibungsloser wird dieser ablauf
stattfinden
was sich derzeit von den
militärkommandanten als feedback bekomme
ist das eine sichergestellt ist es
herrscht bewusstsein überall im gesamten
land das etwas zu tun ist
was jetzt konkret zu tun ist ist etwas
was auf der einen seite durch die
bundesebene noch vorgegeben wird aber
auf der anderen seite insbesondere auf
der ebene der länder und speziell auf
der ebene der gemeinden noch zu
koordinieren und abzustimmen sein wird
wenn es also darum geht auf der einen
seite eine teststation also ein gebäude
eine sporthalle eine veranstaltungsreihe
et cetera zu definieren und zu sagen
dort wird eine teststation mit fünf oder
zehn test spuren eingerichtet um dann
sozusagen die gesamte vorbereitung
dieser infrastruktur herzustellen und ab
sind wir auf einem guten weg weil ich
spüre dass hier auf der einen seite
bewusstsein herrscht das etwas zu tun
ist und auf der anderen seite das
bewusstsein vorherrscht dass auch hier
zusammen gearbeitet werden muss und auch
diese aufgabe kann nur zusammen gelöst
werden die nächste frage
die wird gern hat bisserl konkreter
werden
so lange ist es ja nicht mehr wann
werden die leute informiert wo sie
hingehen können wie viele leute vom
bundesheer werden im einsatz sein wie
viele teststationen soll es geben
dieser gesamte vorgang befindet sich
tatsächlich noch in einer planerischen
bearbeitung und daher kann ich diese
fragen so überhaupt nicht beantworten
weil es dazu noch keine definitiven
festlegungen gibt es gibt gewisse
hochrechnungen dass man wir wissen wie
viel personen insgesamt zu testen sein
werden das wissen wir
wir wissen wie viel durchsatz durch eine
test spur wir voraussichtlich haben das
sind jetzt aber rein mathematische
übungen die aber noch
eine konkrete aussage treffen lassen wo
welche teststationen mit wieviel des
spuren einzurichten sein werden das ist
ein prozess der auf der einen seite wie
ich es gesagt habe durch einheitliches
vorgehen von oben hin unter mehr oder
weniger definiert wird und dann auf der
ebene der kommunen klar umgesetzt werden
kann indem man sagt okay wir haben so
und so viele tausend leute zu testen
daher brauchen wir folgende
infrastruktur aber dieser prozess ist in
bearbeitung
wir wissen alle dass sind zwei wochen
der erste durchgang schon vorbei ist
daher bleibt nicht mehr viel zeit ja gut
nächste frage bitte
latino
es gibt eine insgesamte zahlen aus der
slowakei die er so in die bei den
spitzen wochenenden ungefähr 40.000
personen für diesen vorgang verwendet
haben für die gesamte slowakische
bevölkerung von denen rund ein viertel
militär war und ungefähr ein viertel
polizei und der rest sonstiges personal
zur unterstützung
die konkreten zahlen was südtirol
betrifft weiß ich insofern als dass für
die 350.000 personen die getestet werden
hätten sollen also 320 waren sehr real
rund 200 teststationen mit in der summe
600 test spuren der welt eingesetzt
worden sind und auch wenn man südtirol
kennt ja durchaus sehr unterschiedlich
gemacht wurde es gibt dort ortschaften
mit relativ wenig leuten da ist an einem
tag eine test spur eingerichtet worden
und die sache war erledigt weil die
bevölkerung durch getestet worden ist
dort hat man wirklich sehr stark auf die
lokale führung auf bürgermeister auf die
kommunen kommunen geachtet wie sie wie
sie es machen wollen und weil man gesagt
hat jede vorgabe von oben die zu sehr
ins detail geht stört den eigentlichen
betrieb und das hat auch für eine
gewisses ein gewisses
verantwortungsgefühl vor ort gesorgt und
auch für ein zusammenrücken aller jener
die einen beitrag leisten konnten und es
wurde natürlich dann auch in der
slowakei auf der einen seite die
bevölkerung animiert einen kostenlosen
test durchführen zu lassen
auf der anderen seite gab es sogar
firmen die interesse hatten dass ihre
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter diesen
test durchführen und sie haben sie
entsprechend finanziell mit einem bonus
belegt und das personal das sich dort
vor ort im einsatz gefunden hat war
natürlich im dienst das ist beim militär
bei uns genauso
ich unterscheide deutlich zwischen dem
vorgang der testung der lehrer das sind
220.000 das ist ungefähr vergleichbar
und noch dazu auf ganz österreich
verteilt da tun wir uns etwas leichter
ich unterscheide das deutlich von den
der massen testung der gesamtbevölkerung
weil dort funktioniert das in derselben
form und methode natürlich nicht weil
diese kräfte hat das bundesheer nicht
und deswegen betont nochmals dass das
dann eine angelegenheit sein wird die
sehr stark auf gemeinde ebene
abzuhandeln wir oder innenstädten und
auch in der slowakei hat man sich ein
bisschen angelehnt an den wahlsprengel
muss man gesagt hat jeder was ungefähr
wahllokal ist daher wird man in
anlehnung daran eine entsprechende test
straße einrichten und damit
sicherstellen dass die leute dort auch
hin finden der platinum aber sie schon
eine idee oder grobe idee wie viele
leute vom bundesheer dann an diesem
wochenende fünfter sechster im einsatz
sein sollen und die zweite frage die
lehrer und kindergartenpädagogen vom
weltkriegen die eigentlich dann die
information dass sie kommen sollen sie
die vom bundesheer kriegen sie die von
ihren dienstgebern kriegen sie das von
den gesundheitsbehörden also die stärke
des österreichischen bundesheeres das im
einsatz sein wird hängt sehr stark davon
ab wie aufwändig wie die infrastruktur
konstruieren müssen ja aber das sage ich
gleich dazu das ist für die für das was
das bundesheer in der lage ist zu
leisten keine herausforderung die wir
nicht stemmen könnten
das ist nicht das problem die mannstärke
für diese erste test um die art und
weise wie lehrerinnen und lehrer und
kindergartenpersonal aufgefordert wird
zur testung zu kommen ist eine
angelegenheit des bildungsressorts bzw
der bildung
die reaktionen beziehungsweise der
einrichtungen die methode wie diese
einrichtungen davon bescheid erfahren
außer dass wir heute darüber reden und
die ganze zeit in wirklichkeit schon
darüber reden ist etwas was dann noch
konkret durch die bildung vorgegeben
wird
bitte denkt die mannstärke für die erste
testung des bundesheeres ist kein
problem lässt dass die schlussfolgerung
zu für die zweite große massen testung
bereitet ihnen die mannstärke durchaus
kopfzerbrechen
also wir werden die selbe leistung
quantitativ hochgerechnet auf die
österreichische bevölkerung bei der
zweiten test uns sicher nicht erbringen
können weil es nicht vorgesehen ist das
österreichische bundesheer mobil zu
machen
gut gibt's weitere fragen bitte als
hintergrund hätte mich noch interessiert
weil sie gesagt haben sind die zeit
passiert schon wie lange sind sie denn
schon eingebunden als bundesheer oder
wie haben sie dann erfahren dass diese
massen testungen durchgeführt werden
sollen und wie weit ist denn die
beschaffung der test für die sie ja auch
zuständig sind
wir arbeiten eine gute woche an dieser
sache und die beschaffung der tests ist
ja mittlerweile eine aufgabe des
bundesheeres und wir werden die
erforderlichen tests für die
gesamtbevölkerung zur verfügung haben
inwieweit sie sagen sie arbeiten jetzt
eine woche daran da war ja auch schon
öffentlich bekannt dass österreich
massen tests durchführen wird hat sich
das auch auf die auf die weltmarktpreise
der tester ausgewirkt wie leicht oder
schwer ist es da jetzt tests zu bekommen
also über die preisgestaltung habe ich
keine ahnung
es ist aber so dass unsere beschaffungs
organe die beauftragt sind diese
beschaffungen durchzuführen mit den
firmen die wir von denen wir beauftragt
worden sind die tests zu beschaffen ohne
probleme die erforderlichen stückzahlen
bekommen haben gut gibt es noch weitere
fragen
falls nicht und sage ich herzlichen dank
für kommen
positiv denken negativ bleiben